قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو ان اسرائيل ستواصل الحرب حتى
النصر الكامل وحتى هزيمه حماس حسب تعبيره
واضاف نتنياهو ان اسرائيل تتمتع بالحق
الاساسي في الدفاع عن
النفس اسرائيل
الخم اسرائيل تخوض حربا عادله نحن نقاتل
وحوش حماس الذين قتلوا واغتصبوا وقطعوا
الرؤوس وخطفوا مواطنينا سنواصل فعل ما
يسعنا لحمايه انفسنا ومواطنينا الحفاظ على
القانون الدولي تتمتع اسرائيل بالحق
الاساسي في الدفاع عن النفس لقد رفضت
محكمه لاهاي هذا الطلب الفاضحه بحرمانها
من هذا الحق لكن مجرد الادعاء ان اسرائيل
ترتكب جريمه اباده جماعيه ضد الفلسطينيين
ليس كاذبا فحسب بل انه امر مشين واستعداد
المحكمه لمناقشه هذا الامر على الاطلاق
يشكل وصمه عار لن تمحى لاجيال عده سنواصل
الحرب حتى النصر الكامل وحتى نهزم حماس
ونعيد جميع المختطفين ونضمن ان غزه لن
تشكل بعد الان تهديدا لاسرائيل